[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday but in my
heart it's question Tuesday the day that
I answer real questions from real
nerdfighters among all the vitriolic
poorly spelled obscene and frankly not
very nerdfighter ly comments to your
last video there were also many
excellent questions are you doing any
readings or public events in the near
future
yes actually tonight if you're over 21
I'm going to be in Chicago performing it
to hide out with my friend mark Bayes
err what happened in de PUE New York
where a few people were trying to remove
your book from the curriculum a ton of
people went to the school board meeting
on Tuesday which I really appreciate but
unfortunately due to like the obscure
rules of school board parliamentary
procedure none of them was allowed to
speak the five people who did speak all
spoke out against the book although
several of them hadn't read the book one
person said that he didn't have to read
the book because and I'm quoting
directly here you don't have to have
cancer to diagnose cancer that analogy
proves why we need good English
literature education there's another
board meeting on March 4th more info
soon is there an official release date
for Paper Towns
yes October 16th I know I said it was
going to be September but I was lying
god I love lying who the eff is Hank
Hank is a veteran of the CIA Directorate
of operations in u.s. Navy SEAL team
three he is five foot ten inches tall
weighs 170 pounds and has green eyes
Hank was an operative of the Third
Echelon a clandestine division of the
National Security Agency
Hank is extremely agile and an expert in
the art of stealth when in the field
Hank prefers to work alone who's more of
an evil Lady Queen Ronald podría Queen
Rabideau and employee marina Renault
Queen Rabideau Andrew pointy Marina Bay
no I was so close
Queen Rollo to Andrey Queen rabid Owen
who's more of an evil Lady Queen
Rabideau andrey an employee marina ran
up a loan of the 1st yes I did it what a
lady Elizabeth báthory first off I just
like to say to the person who posed that
question that was an excellent spelling
of Queen ran a bellona's first name and
second off definitely Queen ran of Alona
what do you think of nerd fighting cows
obviously I'm in favor of them I mean
everyone knows that drinking milk from
nerdfighting cows is the number one way
to get your recommended daily allowance
of awesome middle brownies or edge
brownies excellent question
edge brownies is Looking for Alaska a
great book or
the greatest book Oh YouTube user USAF
Jeff you sure do you know how to get
yourself on question Tuesdays
sadly Looking for Alaska is neither a
great book nor the greatest book but I
hope that it is you know good
lost or heroes um books are there any
puppy sized animals who you think would
be even better than puppy-sized
elephants well it's no secret that I'm
awfully fond of puppy sized humans how
nerdy is too nerdy let me answer your
question with a question how awesome is
too awesome was the character Alaska in
your book Looking for Alaska based on a
real person yes no I mean in some way
she's based on me but then another way
she's based on other people there needs
to be a word in the English language
that encompasses both yes and like Ness
what's your favorite video game console
strangely the answer to that question is
also Ness what's your favorite anagram
um I'm pretty fond to the fact that
Britney Spears anagrams to Presbyterians
could God create a burrito so hot that
even God couldn't eat it I think that's
what the Buddhists would call a question
wrongly put like I do think that
questions about God's omnipotence are
interesting but ultimately I think the
question for people of faith is how and
whether God works in the world and how
and whether we can participate in that
work if two nerdfighters have a baby is
the baby born awesome or does the baby
have to develop into awesome good
question and I know just the person to
ask
Brotherhood 2.0 resident mathematician
and future state Congress person Daniel
Biss quick question when you were
looking at the ultrasound of your new
baby did it did the baby look awesome
okay thanks they're born awesome if you
were forced to get a tattoo what would
it be well I really would have to be
forced but I'd probably get dftba
tattooed on my hand so that way whenever
I walked into a room and I couldn't
remember what I was supposed to do there
I could be like oh right I'm supposed to
be awesome
who's that figure on top of your
bookshelf I believe you'd be referring
to my black Santa this wall makes sense
when you read Paper Towns are you still
sticking to the four minute time limit
yep